but there is a crucial situation for
anyone who's coming into town from
southern california of course there's
the big squeeze there but take a look
northbound i-15 is completely closed
just north of gene nothing official from
the nevada state police highway patrol
but we've been led to believe that there
may have been a wrong way driver going
south in the northbound lanes of the
i-15 at gene possibly running head-on
into a semi with a fire however we have
been told there is no fatal this was
northbound on the i-15 just a little bit
ago uh here's traffic at the scene being
diverted off to las vegas boulevard in
fact we have our own armando down there
on the scene and this is a live picture
of traffic being diverted off not
exactly a gene but right after gene you
can get over the las vegas bowler
remember that is the road that goes
right by the seven magic mountains rock
sculpture and las vegas boulevard
actually does go all the way up
alongside the 15
up to sloan and saint rose parkway so
once again traffic completely
technically closed at the 15 but being
diverted off to las vegas boulevard
again the rest of freeway system here in
town is pretty good we'll let you know
more when we officially hear more but
it's going to be a slow one coming into
southern nevada from socal john